How about riding a horse in a wide, open space? Just think!
This will help you release your stress.
If you really need something refreshing in your life,...
...Mongolia can be your next country to go to.
This place is, of course, an ideal setting and opportunity...
...for small adventurous and daring groups...
...to experience a way of life that has not changed since the days of Genghis Khan.
Horses have always played a most important part in Mongolia's culture.
It is interesting that infants learn to ride before they can walk here,...
...so anybody can help you with your horseback riding.
Do you feel like going on a trek on horseback now?
There are many short or long riding trips across the steppes...
...where you will pass dunes and strange sandstone formations.
The camp is moved each day with camel-drawn carts.
Visit this country from June to October because the climate is mild and pleasant!